An Israeli
American citizen
was killed today in the West Bank.
This follows an eruption of violence
over the weekend
when rare peace talks between Israeli
and Palestinian officials in Jordan
were overshadowed
by attacks and riots back
home, sparked by the shooting
of two
Israeli brothers near a Palestinian town.
Israeli officials quickly dubbed that
a terrorist attack
and hours later, riots broke out
almost a pogrom, really.
Israeli settlers
throwing rocks
and setting houses and Palestinian
neighborhoods ablaze.
It was shocking and horrifying.
At least one
Palestinian was shot and killed.
CNN's
Hadas Gold is in Jerusalem
with more on what Israeli officials call
revenge attacks.
Benjamin Netanyahu
is the most experienced
prime minister in Israeli history,
but he's facing
unprecedented, multifaceted battles
on nearly every front
between the
tensions and violence
between Israelis
and Palestinians at a 20 year high.
On Sunday,
the occupied West
Bank burned
two Israeli brothers shot point-Blank
killed while sitting in traffic
in what officials say was
a terrorist attack, which was then
in what's been deemed
revenge attacks by Israeli settlers.
A Palestinian man shot and killed
houses and cars burned
just hours after Israeli
and Palestinian officials
met in a summit in Jordan meant
to calm tensions.
A joint communique pledging
to take steps to restore
calm, seeking a just and lasting peace.
So the Knesset gave
Meanwhile, Netanyahu's far right
wing coalition partners
seemingly dismissing
the summit in Jordan.
The messages coming out.
Netanyahu biographer Anshel Pfeffer
says much of the controversy around
Netanyahu is
thanks to these governing partners.
I think this is the least
Netanyahu has ever been in control
as a prime minister.
He's not basically he's
not running his government.
His government is being run
by the coalition partners
who have him over a barrel.
Meanwhile, for eight weeks in a row,
tens of thousands of Israelis
have been taking to the streets
to protest
against Netanyahu's planned
massive judicial reforms.
The most sweeping of these changes
would give the Israeli parliament
the power to overturn
Supreme Court decisions.
Many critics are arguing it's
part of a ploy
to help Netanyahu
out of his ongoing corruption trial.
Something he denies.
Good to see you, Sir Thomas.
Good to see you.
Netanyahu faces
increasing international pressure
from allies, notably the United States,
which has criticized
not only settlement expansion
and some of Israel's actions
in the occupied West Bank,
but also a rare presidential incursion
into internal Israeli politics.
President Biden
urging a consensus be reached
on the judicial reforms.
We've never had
this kind of differences
between Jerusalem and Washington.
It's always been over
the Palestinian issue.
It's been over the Iran issue.
It's never been about the way
the Israeli government is
is legislating on a democratic agenda.
We
looming ahead in the calendar
the highly sensitive period
of overlapping Muslim
and Jewish
holidays of Ramadan and Passover,
threatening to set
Jerusalem aflame as well
Yet another battlefront
for Netanyahu, Israel's
ultimate survivor.
For now, Ben
and Jake, what's really interesting about
those settler rampages
is that the Israeli
military is actually calling them
acts of terror,
sort of rare moment agreement
with Palestinian officials.
We know that at least eight
people have been arrested
in connection to those attacks.
Meanwhile, the Israeli military
sending extra battalions
into the West Bank
to try and catch the attackers
in those two attacks on the Israelis,
as well, as they say,
try to at least
keep the two sides
separated between Israeli
settlers and Palestinians.